to another important topic here at home
fighting back against human trafficking
well it unfortunately happens everywhere
las vegas was found to be one of the
most vulnerable cities for predators
january is human trafficking awareness
month and local organizations are
joining forces
to inform the community eight news net
reporter madison kimbrough joins us now
with the details from a special forum
held today
to bring awareness madison yes today's
forum covered a variety of topics
pertaining to human trafficking
how it is defined how it happens myths
about what it is and the impact it has
on
us here in las vegas talk about some
tough issues
and then just to figure out how we can
be part of the solution
january is human trafficking prevention
month and seeds of hope a branch of the
salvation army spoke at the mob museum
today
for their safety human trafficking
prevention forum
the hour-long informative session gave
new yearly statistics
and also gave tips on what to look out
for and how to help
intimidation manipulation and fraud are
three big components to trafficking an
individual
las vegas is one of 17 u.s cities most
likely to be a destination for human
trafficking victims
joy hoover the founder of the cupcake
girls an organization that provides
aftercare for sex
trafficking survivors and support to
individuals in the adult industry
says that in this past year the number
of cases that were reported to her
organization
were unsettling of the 800 clients we
personally cared for last year we had a
300 percent
increase in clients ex clients
disclosing
trafficking and domestic violence due to
covid over 63 percent of our clients
disclose that they had been or were
currently being trafficked
with the help from the community the
cupcake girls has been able to provide
dental medical financial
and even legal services for their
clients and while bringing
awareness to the issue is key changing
people's view of what trafficking looks
like
is a major component we need to show up
as a community for
anyone that is at risk for or
experiencing this
and we need to fight on the back end to
not stigmatize folks and
put our you know this is what
trafficking looks like because it's very
dangerous for individuals in a community
that don't look like that
and are seeing signs on bathroom doors
of if you know if you're being
trafficked call this number
when literally they are being trafficked
and have no idea
the forum today was one of many that the
mob museum hosts monthly
they've teamed up with las vegas metro
to discuss a range of important
community-based topics to get out to the
public